I started taking five defender mushrooms supplements. Can I have side effects from this after
started and I felt the press instantly and felt nauseous after eating? That's the only thing I did
different. I'm not familiar with that brand. So understand your mushroom, the mushrooms that you want
to take, you want them to be hot water processed mushrooms. So if they're not hot water processed
mushrooms, you could be getting allergic reaction from a mushroom product. That's why we sell
our private labeled mushrooms and host defense mushrooms. Those are the only two mushroom products
that I really recommend is the ones that we've created or private labeled or the host defense
brand mushroom. So I look into that on other mushroom products, a lot of their supplements out there
that can just not be good quality supplements. And I've shared with you multiple times as an interesting
study that was done over a number of years ago now that they took GNC target, Wal-Mart,
Walgreens, and some other store supplements. They took gospel gut and a bunch of different supplements
that they tested and some had like zero of the product in it. So second thing that can be possible
is the capsule. Some people have reactions, some people have antibodies to glycerin, some people have
antibodies to what the capsules are made of and that could be an issue too. So those are the things that
I would investigate. Because typically you won't get those effects from a good quality mushroom.
So it takes something else.